Любі семикласники, вітаю вас
на уроці української мови.
Моє ім’я - Людмила Зленко.
Сьогодні тема нашого уроку:
«Правопис прислівників з однією
літерою -н- або з подвоєнням".
Традиційно перевіряємо домашнє завдання.
А допомагатимуть нам у цьому
наш знайомий Патрік і його друг - Боб.
Пам’ятайте про те, що зібравши
всі бургери з кожного слайду,
де потрібно виконати завдання,
наприкінці ви зможете себе оцінити.
Що ж, починаймо!
З яких частин має складатися анотація?
Їх виділяють дві:
формальна - бібліографія,
та творча - власне текст анотації.
До бібліографії можемо віднести:
кількість сторінок, автора, назву,
видавництво та рік видання.
До тексту анотації: жанр,
тема твору, персонажі,
час і місце, де можуть відбуватися дії,
та адресат,
тобто кому саме цікавою буде ця книга.
Ви знали, наші Патрік і Боб -
великі романтики?
За вікном - весна,
у них ліричний настрій,
тому вони пропонують почати
наш урок з поезії.
Давайте прочитаємо.
Що ж, Патрік і Боб потребують
нашої допомоги.
Якщо вони захочуть зачитати цю поезію
комусь із своїх дам серця,
вони точно не впевнені:
ми маємо писати прислівники
з однією літерою -н- чи з двома.
Давайте розберемося.
Пригадуємо, прислівники зберігають
правопис тих частин мови,
від яких вони утворені.
Тому, насамперед, потрібно повторити,
коли ж відбувається подвоєння,
коли не відбувається у прикметниках.
У прикметниках подвоєння відбувається,
якщо основа прикметника закінчується
на приголосний -н-,
і ми додаємо ще один
прикметниковий суфікс -н-.
Наприклад - денний
Також подвоєння зберігається
у суфіксах -анн-, -енн-, -янн-,
які позначають збільшений вияв ознаки.
Наприклад, нездоланний.
Звертаю увагу, обов’язково
перевіряємо наголос.
Коли подвоєння не відбувається.
Якщо основа прикметника закінчується
будь-якою іншою приголосною,
крім -н- при додаванні суфікса -н-.
Наприклад - братній.
Також подвоєння не відбувається
в прикметникових суфіксах
-ан-, -ен-, -ин-, -їн-, -он-, -ян-.
Наприклад, солоний.
Варто запам’ятати, у цих прислівниках
подвоєння відбувається завжди.
Повернемося до поезії.
Давайте з вами, уже
користуючись правилами,
обґрунтуємо написання однієї
або двох літер -н- у прислівниках.
«Беззахисно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «беззахисний»,
у якому подвоєння не відбувається.
Тому і прислівник пишемо
з однією літерою -н-.
«Беззастережно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «беззастережний»,
в якому основа закінчується
приголосним -ж-.
Тому подвоєння не відбувається.
«Бентежно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «бентежний».
Основа закінчується не приголосним -н-,
подвоєння не відбувається.
«Первісно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «первісний»,
у якому подвоєння не відбувається.
«Первозданно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «первозданний»,
де бачимо наголошений суфікс -ан-,
який позначає збільшений вияв ознаки.
«Первоцвітно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «первоцвітний».
Подвоєння у ньому не відбувається,
тому і прислівник залишається
з однією літерою -н-.
І останнє. «Блакитно» - прислівник
утворений від прикметника «блакитний»,
в якому не відбувається подвоєння.
Прислівник пишемо лише
з однією літерою -н-.
Сподіваюся, ви засвоїли правила
і готові перейти до практики.
На слайді ми бачимо перший бургер.
Не втратьте можливості його заробити.
Нам потрібно знайти зайвий прислівник
у кожному рядку
і обґрунтувати, чому саме він зайвий
за вивченими раніше правилами.
Подумайте!
Зайвим словом у рядку буде
прислівник «старанно».
Тому що у ньому, на відміну
від двох попередніх,
буде відбуватися подвоєння.
Друге.
Зайвий прислівник - «незліченно».
Тому що, на відміну від двох інших,
у ньому подвоєння відбувається.
Який прислівник зайвий у третьому рядку?
Зайвим є прислівник «охайно».
Тому що, на відміну від двох інших,
в ньому подвоєння не відбувається.
Останнє, четверте.
Який із запропонований
прислівників зайвий?
Ви праві, якщо стверджуєте,
що зайвим є прислівник «вільно».
На відміну від двох інших, у ньому
подвоєння не відбувається.
Молодці! А тепер трішки часу для ребусів.
Я впевнена, що ви знаєте,
як саме їх розгадувати.
Але про всяк випадок я вам допоможу.
Розглянемо уважно зображення.
Першою на ньому ми бачимо
героїню відомого мультфільму,
яку звуть Марія.
Ніжно ми можемо назвати її Маша.
Запишемо це слово.
Звертаю вашу увагу, що картинка
розміщена догори ногами.
Це означає, що нам потрібно
наше слово повернути.
Кома перед зображенням Маші означає,
що першу літеру ми повинні прибрати.
Кома після зображення Маші означає,
що прибираємо літеру останню.
Тобто ми маємо перший склад - ша-.
На другій картинці у нас розміщений слон.
Запишемо слово.
На картинці вказано,
що першу літеру нашого слова
ми повинні замінити літерою "Б".
Давайте це зробимо.
Ми майже на фініші. Останнє слово - гном.
Нагадую, кома до зображення означає,
що ми прибираємо першу літеру.
Кома після зображення вказує на те,
що потрібно прибрати ще й останню.
Давайте перевіримо.
Ми отримали прислівник, у якому буде
відбуватися подвоєння.
Саме за таким алгоритмом пропоную
вам розв’язати наступні ребуси
і з’ясувати, в яких трьох прислівниках
також буде відбуватися подвоєння.
Правильна відповідь - «старанно».
Якщо ви були праві, бургер ваш.
Наступний слайд.
Правильна відповідь - «сонно».
Якщо ви не помилилися,
ще один бургер ваш.
Останній, третій ребус.
Правильна відповідь - «незмінно».
Що ж, я впевнена, ви впоралися
з цими не надто складними,
але веселими ребусами.
Тепер саме час перейти до виконання
наступного завдання.
Переходимо до наступного завдання.
Перед собою ми бачимо прислівники.
Наше завдання - розподілити
їх на дві колонки.
До першої записати ті, у яких буде
відбуватися подвоєння,
до другої - ті, які писатимуться
лише з однією літерою -н-.
Ця вправа з ключем, тож, якщо ми
виконаємо завдання правильно
і підкреслимо у виписаних словах
четверту від початку букву, -
прочитаємо ірландське прислів’я.
Тож будьте уважні, приготуйте зошити
та ручки і працюйте разом зі мною.
Перша колонка - прислівники,
в яких подвоєння буде відбуватися.
Друга - де подвоєння не відбувається.
Пригадуємо правила.
«Хибно» - прислівник, у якому подвоєння
не відбувається.
«Недавно» - прислівник утворений
від прикметника «недавній»,
у якому подвоєння не відбувається.
Відповідно, прислівник зберігає
правопис прикметника.
«Старанно» - утворений
від прикметника «старанний»,
в якому подвоєння відбувається,
тому і в прислівнику подвоєння є.
«Спросоння» - подвоєння
відбувається завжди.
Рухаємось далі.
«Незборено» - від прикметника
«незборений»,
у якому подвоєння не відбувається.
«Беззмінно» - від прикметника
«беззмінний»,
у якому подвоєння відбувається.
«Безупинно» - від прикметника
«безупинний»,
де подвоєння відбувається.
«Задумано» - від прикметника «задуманий»,
у якому подвоєння не відбувається.
Що ж, користуючись нашими правилами,
далі продовжуйте самостійно.
Сподіваюся, ви були уважними
і старанними при виконанні завдання.
Давайте перевіримо.
Подвоєння буде відбуватися
у прислівниках з лівого стовпчика.
Подвоєння не відбуватиметься
у прислівниках у правому стовпчику.
Це завдання було непростим, але
залишається відшукати та записати ключ.
Нагадую, для того, щоб визначити
правильно ключ,
нам потрібно підкреслити у виписаних
словах четверту від початку букву.
Давайте прочитаємо ірландське прислів’я.
Якщо ви виконали завдання правильно,
зможемо прочитати ірландське прислів’я:
розуму з віком набувають.
Що ж, погоджуватися чи ні - справа ваша.
Але я впевнена, після виконання цього
завдання ви стали ще розумнішими.
Два бургери - ваші.
Давайте підсумуємо, зігравши в гру.
Ви пам’ятаєте кольори світлофора.
Червоний означає «Ні! Йти заборонено!»
Зелений означає «так, все добре».
Зачитаю вам декілька тверджень,
ви спробуйте обрати червоний чи зелений
колір відповідно до того,
довіряєте ви цьому твердженню чи не дуже.
З двома літерами "-нн-"
пишуться прислівники,
утворені від прикметників з подвоєнням?
І це - правда.
У прислівниках зрання,
спросоння, навмання,
попідтинню, попідвіконню - пишемо -Н-?
Це - неправда.
У цих прислівниках завжди пишемо -нн-.
Дві літери -нн- пишемо у прислівниках,
утворених від прикметників з
наголошеними суфіксами -анн, -енн, -янн?
І це - правда.
Що ж, ми сьогодні добре попрацювали.
А тепер час обговорити
ваше домашнє завдання.
Будьте уважні та користуйтеся
вивченими правилами.
Друге.
Завдання на екрані
Третє, останнє завдання.
Настав час оцінити себе.
Якщо ви за сьогоднішній урок зібрали
всі 7 бургерів із 7 - класна робота.
Від 4 до 6 - ви працювали
старанно, але, можливо,
трішки не вистачило уважності.
Від 1 до 3 - Патрік і Боб наполягають,
щоб ви повторили правила ще раз
і виконали домашнє завдання.
А наш урок підійшов до свого завершення.
До нових зустрічей на уроках
української мови. Бувайте!